Ciao a tutti, ciò che vorrei condividervi oggi è la mia esperienza col bullismo
Esistono varie forme di bullismo, esistono varie forme di aggressione
da quella fisica a quella verbale. A volte però secondo me forme di
bullismo e forme di aggressione si
nascondono anche dietro gesti molto più piccoli
Andavo in seconda media e c'era
questo ragazzino nella classe di fianco
che... ricordo ancora mi dava del frocio.
Lo faceva sempre quando io mi stavo
allontanando magari all'uscita di scuola.
Lo faceva quando non lo vedevo. Lo faceva
perché... altri suoi compagni
ridevano e quindi questa cosa magari lo faceva
sentire più forte davanti ai
loro occhi. Magari forse lo aiutava pure
a nascondere il fatto che secondo me
lui fosse gay.  Non glie l'ho mai detto
Se sta vedendo questo video sa di chi sto
parlando. E l'unica cosa che ricordo è
che ogni volta che mi insultava mi
uccideva. Forse perché da una parte io
non avevo la forza, non ho mai avuto la
forza di rispondere a quegli insulti
Non avevo la forza di seguire i consigli
degli amichetti che mi facevano "Oh ma tu
spaccagli la faccia, prendi la catena del
motorino, sfondagli lo zigomo, sai chi che cazzo è Django?!"
Cioè ragazzi no. Forse se avesse reagito
in maniera più forte e l'avessi minacciato anche io
avessi parlato la sua lingua
forse lui avrebbe smesso. Il problema è che
io quella lingua non l'ho mai parlata e
non lo parlo, il problema è che si
capisce. E per me è sempre stato da
piccolo un motivo di vergogna
Odiavo andare a scuola quindi. A volte fingevo di star male. Se sapevo che c'erano
delle gite insieme con quella classe evitavo. Questa cosa ovviamente mi ha
portato a chiudermi... tantissimo. Non
vedevo l'ora che finissero le medie e
non vedevo l'ora di andarmene. Al liceo
infatti è stato per me più facile sia
perché in classe avevo  mio cugino che
era molto più bulletto di me e quindi un
pochino mi proteggeva, o almeno è una cosa
che ho scoperto più avanti col tempo
Lì per lì non me ne ero reso conto e sia
perché sono diventato bravissimo
a fare il camaleonte. Cercavo un pochino di
leggere chi avevo davanti e fare in modo
di trattarlo e dire a quella persona
quello che voleva sentirsi dire
Internet mi ha dato la possibilità di...aprirmi e
mi sono reso conto che là fuori
esistono molte più persone simili a noi di
quanto non...non pensiamo. Magari non abbiamo
avuto la fortuna di averle nella stessa
classe. Magari non abbiamo avuto la fortuna
di incontrarle a lavoro e magari in alcuni
casi non abbiamo manco avuto la
fortuna di averle a casa. Ma la fuori, state
sicuri, che esistono persone che non
pensano che voi siete sbagliati per come
siete
Non c'è cosa più bella dell'ascoltarsi
e della accettarsi per come si è
nell'essere apprezzati per ciò che si è
veramente. Io non credo che queste
persone possono vantare lo stesso
privilegio
Per finire questo video torno un secondo al...
all'inizio e al bulletto che mi trattava
di merda alle medie. Stiamo parlando di
tredici anni dopo. A quell'età avevo già avuto
le mie soddisfazioni... i video, i libri e radio deejay
e un sacco di cose... fiche. E ricordo che
stavo a un  ristorante e ad certo punto sento
questa voce che mi dice "Oh Guglielmo!"
Io mi giro e ho davanti questo cameriere. Metto a
fuoco la sua faccia e mi rendo conto che è lui
E lui mi fa
"Ti ricordi di me?" Per un istante avuto la
tentazione di dirgli "Certo che mi
ricordo di te, tu se quello che mi ha
rovinato completamente le medie. Senti
che facciamo? Mi giro e mi urli frocio?
E poi che fai vai a nasconderti?" E poi mi sono detto "No,
non rispondergli così, fregatene!"
Quindi mi ricordo che gli feci
una cosa tipo "Guarda non mi ricordo
minimamente chi sei". Cioè lui ci provava a
farmi ricordare chi fosse "Ma come ero
nella sezione C con Tizio, Caio e Sempronio. Eravamo
amici di Chiara, Luisa" e io stavo li tipo
"Guarda ti giuro non me lo ricordo
assolutamente!". L'unica cosa che gli dissi è
"Guarda senti...vorrei un po di acqua frizzante grazie"... e finì lì.
E mentre mi versava l'acqua io ho proprio pensato a come la vita sia assurda
Potevo non dirgliene quattro, glie ne potevo dire...quaranta. E non l'ho fatto
e sapete perché?
Perché non m'andava di essere un bullo. Cioè non gli volevo dare il
potere di tirarmi fuori della cattiveria
arretrata nei suoi confronti.
Magari chi non l'ha mai vissuta penserà che
sia una cosa molto più stupida
di quanto...di quanto io non la faccia
La cosa positiva però che è che questo video non è per
quelle persone ma è per chi sa esattamente
di cosa sto parlando.
Sappiate che la violenza al contrario di
come ho fatto io
va combattuta e va combattuta con
intelligenza non va combattuta
con cattiveria. Lasciate se non avete la forza voi
che i vostri genitori o i vostri amici agiscano
per voi. Non abbiate paura di parlare con
tutte quante le autorità il cui compito
è quello di proteggervi
perché le vere conseguenze che fanno male sono quelle
che vengono al momento in cui voi non fate niente
Io ve lo auguro, perché è
una sensazione meravigliosa
Arriverà un momento in cui il cerchio si
chiuderà e voi non dovrete fare niente
non dovrete dare nessun tipo di resto, vi
basterà semplicemente non dare la mancia